obeying them all my man boom-boom go all
right hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to the west
of loathing dlc reckoning if gun manor
my cheeks are still how that [ __ ]
hurt my cheeks are still puffy cuz my my
teeth holes still hurt I can't say my
teeth hurt because the holes where my
teeth were hurt but we're back in the
manor Oh doing the funky little dance
we're back in the manor and we need to
go if I remember correctly are we on the
second floor of the third floor third
we're on the second floor okay let's go
back up to the third floor we only just
started exploring this area mr. gun and
mrs. gun okay Oh mr. guns manliness room
well I'm the man hi oh this guy doesn't
notice you approaching until you right
next to him he yelps in surprise and
drops his glass on the floor
then squints unsteadily at you then he
takes a mat maraschino cherry what the
[ __ ] then he takes it sorry sorry
something very weird just happened off
to the side then he takes a maraschino
cherry from a bowl on a bar card and
throws it at your head hey stop that
sorry just making sure you're not one of
them ghosts he drops in on the cherry
into a fresh glass and pours a lot of
whiskey on top of it are you one of the
museum employees mm-hmm yep that's me
what are you doing in here
hidin buddy I don't know maybe you
didn't notice but this house this house
this house it's got ghosts in it you
don't say Oh bunch of them all over I
don't know about you but I'm staying
right here where it's nice and drunk
I mean safe when you rather get out of
here now the booze that is booze I'm
really scared of one ghost go boo you
know they'll get me if I leave this room
there aren't any ghosts between this
room and the exit so you say said that's
what you said they're ghosts that could
be anywhere except in here exactly
I ain't leaving without a guarantee that
those ghosts won't grab me on the way
out we could disguise you I have a
shower curtain why do I have a shower
curtain here look we'll use this white
shower curtain to disguise you as ghosts
then they won't bother you on your way
out that's it
yeah but he tossing back is drinking
pours another but no eye holes that
curtains got no holes for eyes I won't
be able to see I'm starting to think you
don't actually want to leave no one
could do that idea it's terrible in here
shoot some holes in the curtain you
narrow your eyes out of him blast some
holes in the curtain with your pistol
okay okay Jesus I get the picture he
grabs an arm load of bottles from the
cart pulls the shower curtain over said
it staggers out the door good man he's
lucky I could have put it on his head
and then shot the eye holes then who
wouldn't to bet none to have then he
would have been a ghost oh nevermind
Musil employer has drunk a lot of these
carts can contents but there's a few
bottles left okay Manley's finest cotton
candy schnapps okay cool
it's a humidor full of cheap cigars oh I
got a cheap cigar this is for a cigar
for people who want for some reason to
appear to have spent a lot of money on a
disgusting habit without actually
spending a lot of money on it okay grab
another one okay you've got plenty of
them at this point I don't know could I
have more from the smell of it mr. gun
mostly burned garbage in this thing okay
let's go what's this weird if you were
going to commission a painting of swords
you'd think at least you did look you
did least think you deadly you think
you'd at least ask for nice swords I am
dumb bowling is go no wait oh wait no no
I know what that's gonna do this poster
is clear in its artistic content but not
very imaginative oh no big red button
nothing happens you sure you sure okay
anywhere the bowling balls would come
out if this thing worked this bowling
stuff is extremely broken it's not
supposed to be flying around even a
little bit alright okay
I'll fight it got the jump on him yeah
I'm not sure about that but uh okay sure
mr. Cal D and then do I have like a
heavy bullet forget it
bang okay god I'm too powerful for this
DLC I really am
I got a bowling pin carry this around
we'll save you the trouble of hurling
your enemies all the way down a bowling
lane to hit them with it yeah okay that
makes sense I got a jumbo shrimp fork
that's got the moxie I'm gonna keep that
oh good the XR fit 85 was complete trash
[Music]
all right Oh what stuff
Frick what what what why is there
another one wow that didn't actually
kill it oh that's in that oh there we go
yeah whoa holy [ __ ] Gary go easy on them
bowling ball chunk this chunk of a
bowling ball isn't big enough to do
anything other than throw out something
is useful in combat deals damage equal
do your muscle okay sure whatever it
could have sworn the bowling his good
side was gonna turn into boo oh like
this wow you hope you never have to move
a live duck this big it's sickening
killing a helpless sofa and stuffing its
carcass as a grizzly ah shut up oh shut
up
one of the mooses eyes is loose pop it
out oh now it's really got its eye on
you shut up this glass is either
this is either a prosthetic eye made of
glass or a very McCobb marble a mock
arbol
shut up this is just that of a teddy
bear they didn't even remove the tag all
right
so many polyesters died just to decorate
rooms like this right these antlers are
made out of paper mache apparently by
somebody who had never seen the antlers
before the whole rack a whole rack of
bowling
I was looking at the guy playing five
finger fillet but then I saw that the
Goblin alright if they were barreled
billiard trophies would be easier pun to
make weight okay okay
table covered in knife marks ah there's
a goblin net mounted like a trophy on
the wall this would be positively
barbaric if not for the fact that the
Goblin seems pretty okay boo ha ha ha
pretty good I am getting you HOT human
oh wow yeah very much getting me nice
what is did happening to you did mr.
Gunn hunting you and - cutting head off
no oh no mr. GaN a good human man is
being friends inside one of his bowling
ball bags mice poor to growing only
Headroom mr. Gunn to finding me and
hanging me up here for to chatting with
great guy Wow weird ok goodbye
you can tell this is fake because it
isn't floating around the room setting
stuff on fire this is just a photograph
of a fish mr. Gunn was apparently really
liberal with his definition of trophy
alright this ghost is dressed up as a
traditional Safari hunter with the pith
helmet and big white moustache the
colonel and those weird khaki trousers
that make it look like your bud has
wings he's inspecting mr. guns trophy
collection but doesn't seem particularly
impressed
hi I'm mom floor thumper ding hmm Todd
I'm sure Lord
Huston cam Denton at your service what
happened here if you don't mind my
asking not at all not at all though it
is a very exciting story hey what I was
hunting lions and the plains of the
Serengeti as one of the blighters got
the better of me wow you're eaten by a
lion that sounds pretty exciting yes
well not eating this such sneaky bugger
crept into the camp and pushed a stack
of ammunition crates over on me oh maybe
I can help you
help me do what well help you with
whatever's keeping you as a ghost though
now I say it I guess there isn't much I
can do to help you get revenge on a line
oh no no it isn't about revenge that's
keeping me here good for that line I say
turnabout is fair play and all that hey
what though I do wish he'd done it in a
matter they made for a better story so
why are you ago sin it's because of my
one true regrets
I never faced the most dangerous game I
am definitely not going to help you hunt
people what no no no the most dangerous
board game nobody was ever willing to
play against me a Bally shame here what
what's the game he leads you over to a
small table on which has laid a board of
alternating red and black squares with
little wooden disks painting red and
black as well
checkers checkers jumpin scatter as the
ghost stabs two large hunting knives
into the center of the board knife
checkers Oh what are the rules do you
know how to play checkers
yes do you know how to stab someone in
the hand with a knife
yes saul's do you really need to know
[Music]
okay I'll play
you went yank ooh one of the knives out
of the board and Lord Houston instructs
you to hold it left-handed the rules are
you may only attack your opponent's hand
and only when they are over the board
displays checkers are played from where
they land but attacking the board
directly as a foul which Awards the
opponent a stab free turn it appears to
be primarily a game of concentration
quick movements and fainting I need 50
muscle to play aggressively I have 50
muscle I guess I didn't think I had that
much muscle yeah I do that you start out
the game by attacking quickly and
fiercely to establish dominance and keep
your opponent from developing his pieces
the strategy is somewhat affected but
Lord Austin doesn't scare easily he
manages to feign a few pieces past your
guard you enter the mid game more or
less evenly match play intelligently in
the mid game you focus more on the
checkers than on your knife work
maneuvering into position for some big
gains new long-term you suffer a few
minor Nicks and cuts put a well
positioned for the end
game-play craftily Lord goostin spots a
hole in your defenses he faints left
then quickly slides one of his pieces
into the gap and into your trap this
move his moves his hand into the just
the position you need to attack it with
the hard downward stab he easily Yanks
his hand out of the way and your knife
hits one of the pieces on its edge
flipping it across the board to land
neatly in this back rank King me Oh
I say it's a foul to attack the board
sure but I wasn't was I I attacked your
hand and you dodged that's all you
sneaky blighter you play continues but
with the King behind lord houston's line
you clean up fairly quickly all right
lad I concede marvelous play what well
done
he gives you a smart salute and fades
away into nothingness 180 XP whoo
I did it I guess man my cheeks hurt I
taste blood it's not a good I've been
talking all day and I should not have
been I did a stream today not a good
idea
pretty much everything I've done
everyone hold on to your tits everyone
hold on to your buckets
it's a [ __ ] switch here's a spittoon
ear of bright shiny beautiful spittoon
oh boy oh yeah come to Papa what are you
doing huh nothing what are you doing
looking at someone who's kneeling next
to a spittoon with the apparent
intention of sticking diamond you Jam
your hand into the spittoon up to the
shoulder and find nothing
the brass bucket is shiny and clean
outside and in cleanness the museum
staff wasn't washed it it looks
brand-new are you crying no I'm fine
you're crying okay well I'll just be
over here whatever you're done lying on
the ground in a fetal position in
hugging a spittoon
[Music]
No
okay fine whatever grab one you got this
what you inspect and take the best one
what's the point of life I now get while
these ghosts just stick around long
after they're dead because life was just
a disappointment why can't death also
just be one big [ __ ] disappointment
god damn it [ __ ] me okay here we go I
got a wobbly billiards cube the thing
about people who buy billiards tables is
that they are almost never the kind of
people who will properly maintain their
cues this cue does not provide evidence
to the contrary negative-1 moxie great
looks company too bad you're too busy to
sit down and table bears the scars of
many unco stirred beverages or whatever
whatever what's the point of life hi
hard billiards this is both the biggest
and dumbest poster you've ever seen huh
there's a trapdoor in the ceiling over
here too bad you aren't like 11 feet
tall good to know hey buddy
hey how's it going I ain't interested in
chitchat fella just billiards step up or
shut up all right you pull out your cue
and the ghost nods and racks the balls
he utterly trounces you you just can't
seem to make the balls go where you
intended that was a sad showing as I
have ever seen let me see that cue yeah
that's your problem
this thing's about as straight as the
bankers handshake well you're gonna need
to lay this back it to true if you want
a chance against me lathe huh I know my
way around a lathe one of the most
lethal things ever so he is tack or
whatever okay well that was mr. guns
room what about mrs. guns room the store
is locked and no earthly force can open
it well maybe whole team of horses but
good luck getting them up the elevator
okay knock knock yes who is it this gun
a monthly fun burning but you with the
ghost extermination people yes ma'am
Florence Cunningham Cunningham goes to
nine leaves and services mom Fleur is my
assistant come here what
who's the country who's the county
license go center here you mere you okay
fine I guess
have you been able to
exterminate all the ghosts I still feel
for haunted eleven of them left
according to the scanner we're still
working on the man
don't you worry you can count on us the
whole rise please let me know when
you've finished all right sure whatever
okay music room have they been in there
no I have not hello crazy this woman
doesn't seem to be interested in
anything other than cranking the
hurdy-gurdy okay you definitely
disconnect the crank from the
hurdy-gurdy without alerting the woman's
attention but it turns out you needn't
have bothered she continues to turn the
crank blank-eyed with even nothing
attached you grab the end of the crank
and pull her very slowly to the gift
shop where you find a Victrola to plug
her into problem solved Oh weird uh
freak am i what huh what she seems just
as happy years he was before it's nice
to have a calling what what oh hey
thanks for asking me from the hedge maze
hello
either I never asked you what you do
here I've already forgotten I run this
token smashing machine if you buy one to
the commemorative tokens from that other
machine over there I can put it in this
machine here to rule it out flat
well flatter and sample with our logo on
one side and a fun picture on the other
can I interest in you Arnold
sure oh you need to token first you can
buy them from their little machine over
there on the next counter why don't you
sell them yourself
she looks cheapest alone let me have
access to the tokens apply anymore
because I have too much fun smashing
them ok sign says genuine gun manners
souvenir token make your wishes come
true just three hundred fifty meet how
do I negotiate a better deal with a
machine well I got dickering so let's do
it
in a staggering a display of business
acumen you convinced me to give you
discount okay cool yeah alright let's
see what it does
Hey here we go great a love runner this
thing is so satisfying what picture do
you want ooh I want a cool pistol a
sweet oh cool pistol good choice someday
it'll make a lot of people uncomfortable
if you tell me you think pistols are
cool but
here in 1895 hahaha she takes your token
[ __ ] machine happily turns the crank it
makes a loud grinding noise and your
token drops out and into the slot
somewhat longer and thinner hey that's
pretty good
ya want to smash another one yeah I'm
good I'm gonna quit this one it's pretty
good goes in my off hand so it's not the
sweet-smelling flowers it's a [ __ ]
gun token ha ha ha
as if I needed to be more powerful
there's an old frame photograph of mrs.
gun on the wall with a little
explanatory plaque underneath ok the
photograph is a of a young mrs. gun
smiling as she accepts of fancy trophy
from man in a suit a frowning man
wearing a lab coat is standing behind
her the plaque reads Terry got an
assistant accepting the 1869 why didn't
we think of that Award for Excellence in
inventing from the National Academy of
profitable Sciences Zephyr inventing the
gun I guess having greeted you he's now
stands perfectly silent Oh ask for some
info oh hi thanks again for freeing me
from that book you're still kind of at
markzware the engravings pressed into
your face I'm hoping that they fade with
time but if not I can always quiz myself
while shaving so what do you do I
provide information want some yeah sure
great this one I'm here for what would
you like to know
mrs. gun her full name is Teresa Olivia
gun
blah blah blah born in 1847 blah blah
blah unpleasant disagreement blah blah
blah invent gun blah blah blah blah blah
married husband and blah three daughters
okay
blah blah blah not too loud to know very
private person blah blah historical
foundation blah blah locked herself four
years ago okay how about the family blah
blah married damn staple remover blah
blah inventor of the staple remover blah
blah take her last name he wanted to
call as I mentioned office numbers blah
blah
annoyed that people called it after him
instead three daughters Dorothy Blanche
and Rose blah blah Dan vanished in 1889
shortly after Rose is born the blah blah
certainly seem to have killed by Vince
blah blah blah blah blah no ransom note
blah blah never the same start blaming
it on ghosts blah blah blah
no ghost activity here until just the
other day okay gun manner
isn't it amazing mr. gun had it built in
mid to late 70s blah blah blah coal
filed Boulder bowling alley blah blah
library blah blah blah Historical
Society blah blah dumbwaiter blah never
come out of a room since blah blah
telephone house intercoms
okay how about rocks great I know ton of
stuff about rocks specifically igneous
rocks and granted in particular did you
know that granite contains at least 17
to 25 percent quartz which makes it
useful as a resistor in all kinds of
magical devices weird tell me another
one bran is frequently used as a
building material due to its size
strength and pleasant gray color go for
it again keep going
how about another one there we go more
more more more more more more more more
more more more more more more more more
more more more more more more okay he's
repeating himself okay goodbye no one
here no one here hey the guy from the
bar card is leading heavily against the
display of shot glasses with different
names etched on them a sign on this
display reads personalized shot glass is
1200 meet the guy picked up with a
bottle set behind the display and fills
the shot glass labeled Edwin say your
name Edwin he didn't answer alright okay
oh it's you my hero and Savior oh well
leave me alone I'm busy
apparently alright fine goodbye this is
where they all go then listen here the
carriage door is locked but you've got
the key unlock it then oh okay hello
maybe there's something useful in this
cabinet there is there is something
useful you got a nearly empty herbicide
can and a handful of nails great what do
I do with those this Kansas says it'll
instantly kill all plants but it feels
like there's only one plants worth of
deadly chemicals left time--was would
have been Brad's but nowadays man does
not live by bread alone
okay pair of old hedge clippers alright
your uncle used to refer to these things
as shrub scissors these ones look a
pretty effective tetanus delivery device
okay don't know why one would need that
but all right
whew they they had their own custom
stagecoaches okay I'll talk to that guy
in a second is that a lathe hang on wait
a second
this guy's slouching around here smoking
a cigarette hi-yah hey do you work here
are you a parking attendant or something
yeah I guess I validate people's parking
in that can you I'm on break oh well
really everyone's on break
kinda what do you mean well whole bunch
of ghosts showed up and one of the
carriages all of a sudden everyone's
either hiding out or kidnapped hi I got
here in a ghost carriage oh man did I
die somewhere not notice am ia ghost the
guy jabs your forehead with one finger
ow
nope convinced him to get back to work
is that kind of there gonna be enough
okay well you should probably get back
to work now yeah why is that cuz I'm
gonna rescue all the other employees and
if they come back and catch you slacking
off they'll be ticked jeez okay fine
just let me finish the smoke before you
get all heroic okay all right goodbye
then see pile of loose boards build
something hammering nails
why why would I need it Oh No Oh No
[Music]
and it's too silly shut up go to hell
so lave and maybe you can make that
billiards queue less wobbly or I could
wrap myself up in a horrible industrial
accident you lathe rinse and repeat oh
[ __ ] you until the queue is fixed
balance Billy is cute ah that's nice I
like that
is that more Moxie than I've got in my
jumbo nope no sir okay here I go you'll
be diddly did Liddy how do I get back to
where I was before
I don't even remember I gotta go back
into the the maze at some point but I've
got too much to do here so I might as
well just skedaddle up to the third
floor go back into the billiard room and
challenge you you you yeah you with this
all right let's do this buddy let's do
this you pull out your cueing the ghost
nods and racks he proceeds to crush you
something feels wrong like your cues and
connecting with the brawl properly the
ghost shakes his head you're totally new
to this ain't yet
you got a chalk your cue chalk huh can I
borrow yours
mine's ghost chalk wouldn't work dang it
oh okay none for me then what a big
waste of time
what a big lumpy waste of time okay
let's go back to the first floor I feel
like there was something in the basement
that I need so I feel also like my face
is swelling up but that's okay I'm not
too worried about it
it was there something here wasn't there
something like in the science room that
I needed I don't remember
okay all right here mess with them
maybe not maybe I'm just a fool maybe
I'm nothing but a fool I think I'm
nothing but a fool right there but
there's got to be something else than I
need lard larder
largest shelf is full of pots and pan
wait there's a larder and a pantry Oh Oh
a pantry
oh okay this ghost is running around
like crazy
or hovering around like crazy searching
the racks for pants or trousers if you
prefer but we say pants here in the
western territories he seems too
preoccupied to take any notice of you
disguise yourself as pants oh you
sneakily concealed yourself among the
pants and pop out as he approaches boo
I'm pants ah geez bunny who's nearly
scared to death out of me sorry I was
just wondering what you were doing well
I thought it'd be obvious I'm looking
for a pair of pants but you don't have
any legs oh I know it's what do you want
pants for nostalgia no I see kind of
pants you're looking for the kind
without legs legless pants
well I can't wear regular pants you know
legs would just flop around and they'd
be dumb I guess you have a point
God you lose your legs anyway oh geez
it's really embarrassing
I don't mind well see I didn't have a
proper holster from a gun so I was
carrying it tucked in my belt Oh trigger
snagged when you went to draw it huh
right well I mean it gets worse I was
wearing one of those gun belts with the
slots all around for you to stick
bullets in you know oh man the chain
reaction blew off the entire Wow so
that's how you died yes that is how I
died okay I'll keep an eye out for some
legless pans for you thanks I really
appreciate it
well I don't think I'm gonna get any
here am I probably not also they don't
make sense so I don't know what that's
all about
Laura door oh hello decorative fancy
French stuff caviar tootin caviar say
food you don't like wait a second
one of these string beans is exactly 1
point 2 3 3 7 inches in diameter
they must have packed the beans length
[Laughter]
okay hello Oh weird
what do you what you thought was a
framed photograph is actually a window
why does the Larter have a window and
why is this ghost standing motionless in
front of it as if you were a framed
photograph excuse me hello grab them by
the shoulders and shake them ok please
cease this activity of ones sorry I got
a little carried away how about telling
me who you are
ah you do not recognize me jean-francois
are there no what I knew simply
mimicking the photograph would not be
sufficient without it wholly anyone know
I'm the famous France man ever to visit
can mana have a lot of Frenchmen
visiting besides having z-direction
distinction of being the most famous
Frenchman to visit gun Manor
I'm also the first Frenchman to visit
John Manor and the last is well oh gosh
did I I was posing for the photograph
and commemorate my visit here and that
fool of a photographer fault of when
preparing vegan bother flowers
thought of how he left a bullet in it I
see that must have this photograph such
a faces mine must the languish in
obscurity right I don't know if you find
it wasn't there a box of photos in the
basement wasn't there one maybe there's
some pants in the basement - no no no
all right hang on wait no am I on
I'm on the first floor the basement the
cellar was it wasn't this look through
them you got a photo of largest guy okay
cool
no wait hang on let me look at it first
never know what's gonna do nope nothing
ok nevermind no point to that I guess
I'll just drop it off swollen cheeks and
all
hello I found an old photograph my
mother yeah Oh marvelous what our
resemblance yeah it's pretty decent pic
good thing light travels faster than
bullets
now my image will not be lost his their
averages of time merci beaucoup my
friend he hangs a photo in the window it
dissipates into nothingness auf
wiedersehen okay that's terrible
that's not good at all all right
whatever okay well that was good I'm
glad I did now I've done this can keep
it together
mum Fleur spices you got that under
control grab a chili pot and put it on
the burden was I supposed to do you're
trying to make chili without a gun in it
so you have to remember to skip the gun
part oh you shake a heaping helping of
chili spices into the pot the next step
is beans
unfortunately find yourself
embarrassingly beamless devoid of
legumes sans had a coughs as the French
would say it better go find some beans
then doesn't their beans in the larder
did not get a can of beans I got a can
of beans but I need to open the can of
beans I it's in the basement again it's
all it's all connected I should have
gone back there I should have gone back
it's all connected this is this thing
here all right here we go get the right
tin san you got some stuffing make a
silent earth you drill a hole in each
end of the can and carefully remove the
beans when you soak the stuffing in a
vat of acoustic dampening chemicals and
carefully jammed in the can
voila silent ow this is a can of
stuffing designed to make it easier for
you to shoot people at Thanksgiving
dinner without getting caught oh okay
I'll silent my pistol you fix this
Islander to the barrel of your be fouled
pistol all right
okay maybe I should have silent did the
worst all right I got that now I don't
know what that did but at least I got
the means and if I got the beans that
means I can make me some chili Tomo make
me some chili beans I thought I did done
get the beans wasn't what I got beans oh
man I thought I had that all right
what's in here
oh whoa nothing bunch of nothing a bunch
of [ __ ] and Nothingness woes in here
Moo I don't know hello
still working on it to hell with your
chili and also you really tickled my
fancy really just really just dick 'old
me really tickled me I love this game I
love this game so much I think I got
everything there I think I got
everything in the gallery I think oh you
yes ah let's go let's go somewhere else
oh wait no let's go all right
read a book Oh what do I need to read
I've forgotten okay whatever whatever
whatever whatever whatever whatever
whatever I'm gonna ask Florence what's
up ten ghosts left on the premises two
on the first floor four in the second
four in the third but my my current
sounds like a real complicated one I
know a real simple solution
oh no no no we're not gonna shoot
anybody there was some book that I
needed
can you help me with library stuff I was
a bug on specific topic oh never mind oh
I don't know where to start
I don't know what to do lost I've lost
and I'm so scared there's gotta be
something here oh wait
ah-ha were you able to find me a new eye
yes kind of how kind thank you very much
she steaks a glass from you and puts it
in whereupon it falls through her and
onto the floor she cuts she picks it up
oh dear it's a little too physical yeah
I wasn't certain that this would work
don't worry this is easily fixed do you
have a hammer I can borrow a hammer yeah
that'll do nicely thank you she takes an
error and pleases the glass eye on her
desk and smashes it too with a precise
crack ah perfect she gives you back the
clamor and plucks the ghost of the glass
eye from the shattered fragments after
blowing the dust off of it she tucks it
into her eye socket that fits much
better does it work well now you mention
it I can't actually see with it is it is
the ghost of a glass eye after all oh
dear this won't do at all what a shame
you know I don't really understand why
your eyes still missing what do you mean
well I always assumed when someone loses
an arm or something it just sticks
around as an owner arm ghost that's why
people say they can feel it itching
sometimes because he's still got an arm
there but it's a ghost it's even called
phantom limb syndrome so logically if
the rest of you becomes a ghost after
that it would hook right back up but
then where did my I go maybe I got
pushed back inside your head the ghost
thinks about it for a second shakes your
head
no that seems wait what I do think I
felt something just then she shakes her
head just again my goodness gracious
keep going it's like one of those
puzzles where you trying to get the
marble in the hole she bends her head
forward and continues shaking
you can almost hear a faint rattling
sound and then a plop - straightens back
up blinking with towards you did it
well me thank you so much dear I never
would have thought of that no problem
have a nice pot time in heaven or
wherever the ghost gives you friendly
waves and fades out of sight that's it
then
Wow wonderful did you figure out how to
make a good old exploding cigar one that
doesn't turn fun and funeral oh I can't
even make basic wordplay funny well it
was kind of clever
never mind all right I've got cigars I
just don't know how to turn it into
explodey cigars how do I do that puff
off you light the cigar and take a
single puff it turns out a single puff
is enough to make you stink for the rest
of the day oh good great gross oh great
glad I did that okay good great alright
well that was fun glad I did that
well okay wait hang on did I go in the
restroom yeah I did
well then where are the hacking hacking
tits oh I wasn't done upstairs that's
right I got I got thrown out of here oh
whoops alright this is a bassoon and you
know what they say it makes an ass out
of n and and what
[Music]
hey I hate you I hate you a fancy new
electric floor lamp a musty decaying
pile of old music books face them almost
all the books are dirty and rotten my
moth-eaten and fall apart at the touch
you do find a copy of Dueling Banjos in
reasonable shape though okay this is a
book of sheet music for the classic song
Dueling Banjos there's a library call
number written on the spine I think
that's gonna help me very much very very
much sheet music you got blank sheet
music play Dueling Banjos I can't play
Dueling Banjos by myself I don't have
enough arms Florence so I only play the
bagpipe but not very well if it's a
bagpipe bagpipe how do you know hey what
about you Gary
hello hello what you know how to play
the piano what it is having so many
square teeth well that's wrong that's an
error all right never mind then hello hi
this is the ghost of an orchestra
conductor unless easily goes to someone
pretending to be an orchestra conductor
either way he's very agitated about
something or he conducting flight of the
bumblebee sorry to interrupt but I can't
actually hear the music what are you
conducting it's the finale of the year
1812 solemn overture by Tchaikovsky
Tchaikovsky
oh yes the 1812 overture sure well that
wouldn't have would have been my second
guess
or is your orchestra like double ghosts
or something what oh I see you know
there's no Orchestra I merely have this
piece of music a rhythmic rut
irrevocably lodged in my head it has
been nagging at me incessantly ever
since my death this is just a guess but
did you die during a performance of the
1812 overture that is very correct very
astute of you and the finale that piece
features and a real actual canons right
is that how you died if it was my fate
to be slain by a piece of music canons
would have been far preferable to my
utter farcical demise what happened the
overture requires several cannons
because it is impossible to load a
single kin and quickly enough to fire as
the score demands
however the stage where we performed on
could not have borne the weight what did
you do I was not informed of the
difficulty until it was far too late to
make any changes
transpired that the stage manager
decided it would be sufficient to give a
box of bullets to the tube you were shot
by a tuba
I was shot well no wonder you ended up
as a ghost oh it isn't the
ridiculousness of my death that troubles
me really accidents happen as with any
of the Performing Arts a colleague of
mine was decapitated by an errant cymbal
during a performance of [ __ ] but got
Paganini's violin concerto number one
such are the risks we take for our art
gosh
the problem is what that the 1812
overture is finale is a very dramatic
and energetic piece with this music
constantly playing itself in my head I
have been utterly unable to find any
piece I'll see if I can think of a way
to help alright well I could play the
Dueling Banjos but I don't know how I'm
gonna go to the library and take care of
this right away because I think this is
gonna give me something to debate with
the lady wait a minute wait a minute
here I was on the wrong floor I need to
go to the library which is on the second
floor my cheeks hurt something fierce
but I'm gonna finish this episode out
can you all be with library stuff found
a book you might want to back ok
investigate aha Dueling Banjos dual law
duly noted let's read this bad boy oh
hell yeah you're reasonably
well-informed about the specific subset
of gun law pertaining to duels and duel
adjacent activities alright cool
awesome that was totally worth my time
hell yeah alright let's go to the
this floor this floor right here yeah
yeah I remember where you are you're not
gonna make yeah yeah yeah I was good
there I know let's go did you get a
crash course and do law I sure did
swell the only thing I didn't really
understand is when it's legal to banish
your opponent to the Shadow Realm
okay well that didn't come up in my case
so don't worry about it great let me
just do a quick review a duels legal
provided is doing exactly two people at
a specific career range time and place
using the same or at least essentially
similar weapons and they have to either
face each other down or quick and quick
draws the opponent a time moment or do
10 paces turn and fire between is that
right that's suggestive it yes so I
guess let's start with telling you
telling me the facts of the case and
I'll interrupt you rudely if I have any
questions alright but if you push me on
trivial nonsense I'll get mad and you'll
have to start over that's fair go ahead
all right MacCready and tim's burry got
into an argument in a saloon on the
evening of June 17th apparently Tim's
very accused Macready of cheating at
poker okay the bartender yelled at them
to take it outside but since it was dark
out they agreed to meet for a duel the
next day then that would be the 18th you
said yes June 1818 78 okay go on well
the next day they both showed up shortly
before noon in the squared off about
thirty feet from each other when Newton
struck Macready fired fast enough the
Tim's Barry didn't get a shot off on
account of having his head shot off
that's pretty much the long and the
short of it I don't have to ask you some
more details on that go ahead what
weapons were they using
MacCready had a 45 caliber Single Action
Army revolver Tim's Bernie had an older
model 36 caliber cap-and-ball Navy
revolver which he loaded with paper
cartridges instead of backing gun powder
by hand objection those are
significantly different weapons are you
kidding me they're both pistols a modern
cartridge revolver bursting an antique
cap and ball loader ridiculous that
antique was in production until 1873 and
was considered one of the most reliable
in popular six-shooters in the
territories furthermore the restriction
against differing weapons and duel is
about pistols versus rifles or the
proverbial knife in a gunfight
whereas a more recent example a nitwit
to argue the law against a professional
attorney geez that's a bit harsh we're
done here
get out no right let's try that again
hey now use that's clearly duh you all
right let's go all right go on I have
questions
plus the name of the saloon already I
got another one what day of the week -
the grumpy on a Monday both see I want
some mouse or another argument there
isn't much to tell the other places had
already get fooled in their hands so
they weren't paying attention tense very
suddenly accused Merck routing of a
dirty dirty cheating varmint and
McCready September II was just sore
because you've been losing all night
okay been accused of it once or twice
before Reno's gambling town a young guy
on the rough part of it getting accused
of cheating by a sore loser when you're
on a lucky streak depart for the course
but if McCready out a history of
cheating it would be irrelevant because
the reason for the duels immaterial to
the legality of the duel itself motive
isn't an issue here but remember I
warned you about ticking me off of
stupid digressions this is an excellent
example objection this is extremely
relevant relevant ah what this is
extremely relevant if McCready was a hit
bejeweled cheater it's likely they would
have cheated in the duel as well now
somehow you're gonna prove that McCready
was a habitual poker cheat 17 years
after the fact how exactly what form of
the mirrors alright well that did I knew
that was going nowhere
all right I'm gonna listen to my gut on
this because I'm not just gonna do the
objection if it just says objection
because that's dumb oh here we go or go
on go I have questions that everyone
what happened for details
Oh fire - exactly noon far too soon as
the church bells trucks yes it's what I
just said if you got a point of maker
you just stalling
well yeah because they didn't count did
they
objection but that can but Creedy fired
at the wrong time what are you talking
about he fired it exactly noon with the
church bells there are witnesses that's
right he fired at o'clock noon but the
Stute the duel is set for high noon ah
see I listened to my instinct was
something wrong here they aren't the
same thing
High Noon is just when the Sun is at his
highest point in the sky depending on
geography and the time of the year it
can be hours different from o'clock noon
MacCready fired early in
makes a duel illegal so what do you say
to that counselor Felicity gives you a
slow smile I've got to hand it to you
prosecutor front / ding you're a lot
better at this than I was giving you
credit for that's a good thought you had
there there's just one problem with it
oh what's that I already thought it'd
take that she hurls a small book at you
what you just barely managed to catch
you got that nautical Almanac what the
heck is this I did my homework when I
was preparing for that trial my legal
homework since at the time I was
expecting there to be an actual trial
not a gunfight what you're holding there
is a nautical Almanac for the year 1878
there are book marks if you'd like to do
the math for yourself but if you look up
solo noon aka High Noon for June the
18th and make the adjustment for Reno's
longitude what do you think you get you
have got to be kidding me
that's right mr. prosecutor 12 o clock
p.m. precisely well damn nice try though
I mean that sincerely that's all my ammo
I can't think of any other way to
disprove McCready's innocence as far as
I can tell it was a fair duel yes and
that's me with the guilt of an innocent
man's death on my hands an innocent
man's death you sure are good at
repeating things people say what if you
didn't die say well now well you didn't
actually see the execution right yes
well I was indisposed you might say
being dead and all so you don't actually
know whether or not it happened oh come
on look I appreciate the effort but
you're barking at the moon Nancy don't
go anywhere
let me ask you something
oh wait
[Music]
see was a trial can you tell me about
Macready gunfighter thing else I'm good
enough numbers another question why did
he invoke trial by combat I was mighty
surprised let me tell you the only hair
can figure is it was damn full sense of
gunfighter pride or something like that
was the only form of justice he was
willing to submit himself to I have
another question was a trial right after
the duel no Rena's like that but it did
have a proper courthouse murder charge
trial didn't start till the 25th so much
for the right to a speedy trial huh
I have another question when was the
execution well we held the trial by
combat on the 26th and those Friday they
don't execute prisoners on the weekend
so presumably it would have been the
following Monday the 29th in the morning
what with setting up the gallows and
letting a crowd gather they usually
happen in the afternoon around 3:00 I
have another question I'll be back I
need to do my research okay I have this
Almanac is this gonna help me is the
Almanac gonna help me look up a date on
it look up a date June July pick a day
how about 25th right those when
McCready's trial started no no special
look of a date July day 26 thursday
Felicity Wainwright was killed by trial
nothing astronomically significant about
it June 17th see there was a moon and
something between new and full good god
this is complicated
this is so complicated that was the day
McCready perform the fight high noon
message is fine in to see me okay well
is there something else is she mentioned
some other date I don't know why the
29th okay I guess I could look up the
29th but I don't know what that's gonna
do let's see it's gonna be my wait a
minute corny this there was a total
eclipse of the Sun that day centered
right over the western territories and
with the totality at 2:47 that's a hell
of a thing
okay what does that mean I looked up
July 29th in your Almanac and there was
a total eclipse of the Sun that day what
now you're just messing with me now look
for yourself
totality at 2:47 right over the western
territories well that's quite a thing
but I don't see how that affects wait
unless you're suggesting right it was
the perfect opportunity for McCready to
escape
that's absurd absurd like a fox I guess
you say yourself that McCready was
really good at remembering dates who
would write about the Eclipse at any
time and store that knowledge away for
the future like to give himself an
advantage in a duel or something
all right that's reasonable as far as it
goes but greedy wouldn't have worked the
clips into the escape plan because he
didn't have anything to say over the
court schedule you said with one the one
thing in another the trial didn't start
until the July 25th McCready could have
caused any number of those delays
himself by faking illness in prison or
messing with the horses on a ride in
Frisco or anything hmm this could also
explain the trial by combat you mean
there ended up being too much delay so
if a regular trial went on too long and
he was found guilty he would have missed
the Eclipse exactly whereas if he called
for trial by combat
everything would be resolved one way or
another and one only one more day maybe
you'd win and that'd be fine but if
you'd lost you could use his escape plan
I have to admit this is pretty
compelling but it's all maybes and
what-ifs yeah maybe it happened but
maybe McCready was ready rescued by
leprechauns oh man are there leprechauns
in Frisco you need some kind of hard
evidence before this is any more than
just a fun story it's what I mean well
let me ask you something else oh my god
how can I find that evidence McCready's
escaped well we don't even know that an
escape happened true something like that
would have been in the news for certain
okay
Oh
Oh start at the bottom of the stack and
flip through them the main feature has
to do with the clips in various axes and
mostly all three minutes kids will be
hanging twenty-ninth and only two of
them escape the confusion Oh keep
looking you don't find anything relevant
to the case however as you're putting
more papers back a headline on the more
recent issue husband of famous inventor
missing the article is light on
information but apparently mrs. Gunn
husband Dan vanished on the road while
traveling to dirt water on business
about six years ago
law enforcement suspect bandits but no
evidence found that's kind of grim okay
I mean it's something we don't have
names people definitely escaped where
Carini could be alive man this is a lot
of back and forth for this one ghost got
question for you I found a newspaper
article the guy's scheduled to be
executed today the clips escaped and one
of them was never caught which one
well didn't say which nope damn it and
executed criminals aren't given
gravestones with their names on them so
you can't just go looking around Frisco
cemetery to find out listen mum Fleur I
really appreciate what you're trying to
do with at this point you would have
actually had you would have to actually
find McCready himself to prove he wasn't
executed due to my failure well I guess
that's what I'll do then how the how am
I gonna find how am I gonna find
McCready what what
right where in where would I find
mccreaney I don't know I have no idea
where I'm McCready would be I don't even
know what a McCready is I'm going over
to a third floor I'm getting out of here
cuz holy [ __ ]
alright that was a big reach around oh
god I have been in here okay did I get
everything in here I think I did boo I
think I did I'm pretty sure anyway right
oh yeah this ghost girl I don't think I
have I'll make tea from your tiny bones
uh
still not getting out can you speak I
don't understand you goodbye - see ya
bye
was there anything in here that I missed
us creepy place
oh the composition of this painting is
bad and that light on ye Oh looks like
this is where the creepy music is coming
from transcribe it okay spooky lullaby
music u2's have transcribed the spooky
lullaby under the sheet music or rather
something use your hand to perform that
operations you don't actually know how
to read music oh good great I'll just
take this here and play the lullaby
where am I
[Music]
he seems to be waving a little oh look
he's smiling ah he's so happy
goodbye Oh where did I go III feel like
I disappeared which is also a problem
well now that was nice that was nice hey
can i oh but his stick his stick I wanna
stick alright I'm gonna go in the hedge
maze outside cuz I think that's that's
where I gotta go I think anyway cuz I
haven't been there I've been deep in it
anyway there's gotta be something in
here cuz I've got like hedge clippers
and stuff like that
loo [ __ ] oh oh that's where that was
okay alright maze Oh locoweed oh wow
yeah you do a quick backflip and then
make some funny noises by flapping your
arms up and down with your hand in your
armpit the locoweed giggles loosening
its fruits just enough for you to pluck
a handful of it out of the ground and
bring it into a little bottle oh all
right
Noor twerk clown wart okay I think I've
gotten these before tea bush
tea tea I don't know what that was all
about meat bush frisco poppy there's so
much stuff was a frisco poppy huh ah
that's nice I don't think I can eat
anything else in shock weed plant be
careful oh wow
arches
point of impact under grow it Oh Bob
sign says tokens only oh I don't have
any tokens would you look at this crazy
thing destroy it dive in I'll fight it
not fight it I don't want to waste my
herbicide I think I only got one more of
those all right here we go come on oh my
god that's so much oh my god
I'm too powerful magic infused leaf what
is that
so tingles with a magical energy that
animated it when it was part of a
malevolent topiary beast yeah okay
whatever all right well there's nothing
here all right
hey these might guys I got beans hey
that's awesome
okay so what I need to do is I need to
go deliver the tea I need to get a token
and I'm gonna get the token I'm gonna go
back to the well and I'm gonna deliver
the tea in them and I'm gonna make the
chili and then I'm gonna deliver the tea
so I got a no not here over here yeah
and get this negotiate a better deal no
I don't think I need a stamp token I
think it needs to be unstamped that's
the thing that would make sense to me so
that's what I'm gonna do I mean I I do
have the brain of an ant and like the
the wit of a shrew but you know I'm
thinking I'm thinking along the lines
that maybe I might be on to something
here
hello I was right you hold the token
over to the well and try to think of
something to wish for after a few
seconds you guys drop the token dang I
wish I had that token back you're some
chimes in a rope appears on the wishing
wells crossbeams well how about that oh
oh
[Music]
this wish was an accident anyway so you
feel entirely justified in taking your
code token back oh okay well that's what
was it what what this shoot but there's
already like Kruk Oh freak me oh hell
yeah I actually have some tea I went the
wrong way I actually have some tea Oh
freak me oh heck yeah oh heck and Hort
oh shoot oh oh [ __ ]
I get it I did it hell yeah alright so I
need to go to the kitchen make some
chili give it to the main man all right
let's do it throwing the spice tossing
the beans no no no God no God no God no
God you restrain yourself from adding a
gun step back and admire your handiwork
it's not according to Hoyle chili
because it doesn't have a gun in it but
it is chili with no gun in it because
Chili's seeding piece stole lace which
is the thing you were after I got it all
right let's get this gun this guy
my cheeks hurt from smiling I gotta
honor of his on gun free chili oh thank
you alright oh wait well it's something
wrong well I can only ghost food how do
I do you need me to murder this chili
for you not to put too fine a point on
it yes alright I'll try to find a humane
way to do it how do I murder how am I
gonna murder this chili do I shoot it so
I need to shoot it
how'd I do that alright let's go deliver
the tea everything's so intricate here
alright creepy little ghost girl hey
want some deer
it's wonderful she serves the tea in the
four of you okay well not the dull sip
it with your pinkies extended in genteel
fashion then with a giggle in a wave she
fades away
rest in peace kiddo oh thank God I would
never be over
look at me I'm shaking like a leaf kind
of freaky situation right having to deal
with the little kids freaks me out bad
enough having to interact with the ghost
of one it was horrifying anyway thanks
for the rescue I need to get back to
work what are you doing here I run the
candy counter at the visitor center
oh okay hello creepy doll okay I guess
by then sure thing creepy doll let go
let's go visit the guy in the gun and
the visitors center and then I gotta get
out of here hello can I please see
something candy related please hello
hello hi candy counter is open oh this
is not what I thought it was oh the
trick is making this kind of candy is
that once the sugar is completely melted
you just keep melting it forever whoa
the secret ingredient what makes it
taste like gunpowder is gunpowder Oh
candy is full of cast off steel shavings
from mrs. guns Factory oh okay well I
don't exactly know what I would sell
here
[Music]
I don't remember any of these actually I
don't remember anything
well whatever I'm not gonna sell
anything I don't need to meet so I'm
just gonna wait I do need something
because I need I need that shot glass I
do need that okay ghost pickle I don't
know if I need that uh what can I scroll
down oh here we go bowling pin
well um man I just don't know what I
needed what I don't need not getting rid
of my spittoon at that's for damn sure
um so like sir just like something I
could throw away I don't know what's
good and what's I guess I could throw
away some of the old clothing I have I
think no no small blue ribbon back if I
sell those I don't know how much I need
to sell how much do I need it for what
does it cost twelve hundred say your
name Bart no no whatever silicone ring I
mean I guess I'll be enough I don't need
the ring it's not a new item it's an old
item actually huh yes a spider pie I
could sell that spider omelette I mean I
don't think I need this ring right you
would I know I'm selling it whatever
[ __ ] here we go give me that [ __ ] I
don't know why you got personalized gun
miter shot glass this personalized
souvenir shot glass from gun Manor
you're excited to use it now that you're
finally old enough to drink gain XP when
you drink booze that's it that's it
that that's it really that is it that's
all like okay you know what whatever
that's those totally worth 1,200 bones
okay whatever so we're gonna end this
here we got a lot more to explore
because I think we got something in the
order of eight or nine seven hey we're
doing much better okay we got seven
ghosts deal with and we're all in like
general final stages of dealing with
them we just got a long way to go so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down the
comments below if you haven't seen the
rest of west of loathing I'll put a link
in the description below check out out
tons of episode funds here is all really
funny really cool to see my face is
gonna heal up soon so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]